sadly this next story has sort of been
buried by other stories but there are
some pretty major developments in the
Trump payoff of a porn star that he had
an affair with and the story continues
to sort of fly under the radar and you
know were not in a normal sort of
situation when the news of a president's
affair with a porn star while married to
a wife who had just had his latest son
followed by a six-figure payoff isn't
even the biggest story of the day
nevermind the week or the month right
but the story is getting sketchier and
more disturbing by the day so to reset
this is the story where it was reported
that President Donald Trump had an
affair with porn actress stormy Daniels
in 2006 he was married at the time
stormy Daniels initially told a slate
reporter that they had an affair that
was sort of a relationship and that
Trump was not sexually skilled and that
trumps lawyer Michael Cohen and her
lawyer came to an agreement where she
was going to get a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars in exchange for silence
on this issue once the story started to
get more attention in the last couple of
weeks both Trump attorney Michael Cohen
yeah that guy and stormy Daniels denied
it Cohen's saying it's not true Daniels
saying I had sex with Trump but I never
had a relationship and I never got paid
very weird very suspicious the entire
thing has been blown wide open and it
seems that the mo would the Trump
administration is they deny and the
denials lead to even bigger revelations
confirmations and sort of undeniable
evidence about the original thing that
they maybe could have just said yeah
it's true in the first place and it all
relates to private LLC's wait a second
pornstar private LLC's well how are
those things connected LLC's are
business entities which can be private
and they can be used to hide the names
of the people who own the companies we
already had reason to believe that Trump
and his family were using private LLC's
to hide real estate deals and hide real
estate holdings and profits but it turns
out according to The Wall Street Journal
that a private LLC was also
used to make that payoff to stormy
Daniels weeks before the 2016 election
Trump's lawyer formed a private LLC
called essential consultants LLC it's
based in Delaware and it's typical that
these entities are created in Delaware
that that's not at all sketchy that's
there's no sketchier I guess then what
most companies do companies typically
incorporated or formed in Delaware and
no further denials so far have been
issued by Michael Cohen nor by by stormy
Daniels but if this is to be believed
it's almost impossible to deny because
the specificity of the reporting
increases every single time that they
deny they deny in more details comes out
Michael Cohen denies again and now we
have the name of the LLC that was used
as well as the timing of its
registration these are liars and they
can't be believed about anything but
here's the real tragedy we are
experiencing not normalization but hyper
normalization we've fallen so far from
some basic standard of an expectation of
decency truth honesty and morality that
not only the facts of this affair and
the payoff are barely registering in the
news cycle the series of lies
surrounding the affair and the payoff
are barely registering in the news cycle
remember when Republicans went nuts
because Obama wore a light tan suit to a
serious event and it wasn't presidential
it seems laughable to think that that
could have been a pseudo scandal and
that Trump's lies about the payoff of a
porn actress through his lawyer are
barely even getting on the radar well I
think it's because with Trump this is
already baked into the cake we know who
the guy is he's a philanderer he's a
playboy is that really out of the
ordinary I mean if it happened to bush
or Obama that would be surprising
because it would go against the
narrative of who we think these people
are right if that's true that is a very
sad state of affairs an incredibly
disturbing state of affairs and there's
no going back from this by having
discourse or whatever right anybody who
has been sort of moved or influenced
into
thinking what's going on is normal
you're not gonna convince them you we've
just got to vote them out that's the
only Pound curious to see what the FOA
explanations gonna be as to why Michael
Cohen set up this LLC week before the
election I wouldn't be surprised if it
was never again mentioned just like we
never hear any comment from the Trump
administration again and it gets swept
under the rug by whatever scandal is
gonna break tonight at 3:30 in the
morning or whatever the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad